AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT BACKING DOWN
AS OUTRAGE FROM THE LEFT
INTENSIFIES OVER A FUNDRAISER
HOSTING BY THE CHAIRMAN OF
EXINX.
URGING BOYCOTTS.
>> I WANT PITCH FORKS OUT THIS
MAN'S HOUSE IN THE HAMPTONS.
>> YOU DON'T GET TO SAY I AM FOR
RACIAL EQUALITY.
BUT I LIKE HIS ECONOMIC VIEWS.
>> YOU OWN THE BLOOD THAT
HAPPENS.
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT SWING VOTERS HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND AND BE SHAMED INTO.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDING BY
DEFENDING STEPHEN ROSS AND
SAYING THE BACK LASH WILL BACK
FIRE.
>> STEPHEN ROSS IS A GREAT
FRIEND OF MINE.
HE IS A SUCCESSFUL GUY.
BY THE WAY, I THINK HE IS
PROBABLY MORE INCLINED TO BE A
LIBERAL IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE
TRUTH.
BUT HE LIKES ME AND RESPECTS ME.
THE CONTROVERSY MAKES ME HOTTER.
THEY WILL FIGURE THAT OUT IN A
WEEK.
HE IS VERY SUCCESSFUL.
I GUESS THEY ARE GOING TO RAISE
11 OR $12 MILLION.
>> MR. PRESIDENT --KNOW.
>> I AM USED TO SAYING BILLION.
>> HE WAS RIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAISED $12
MILLION TODAY.
THE CAMPAIGN IS AWASH IN MONEY.
>> HOW SORRY AND SAD OF A LIFE
DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE TO BE
FOCUSSED ON ENDLESS BOYCOTTS ALL
THE TIME.
GO TO YOUR KIDS SOCCER GAME AND
HAVE POPCORN AND GO TO A MOVIE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE RIGHT
AND THE LEFT.
THE RIGHT BOYCOTTS THINGS
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE'S WAY OF LIFE.
THE BETSY ROSS FLAG.
THE LEFT BOYCOTTS ON THE DUMBEST
THINGS.
ROSS WHO IS CLEARLY NOT A
CONSERVATIVE AND SAID I DON'T
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING DONALD
TRUMP HAS.
HE WANTS CONVERSATION GOING WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY BOYCOTT HIM.
LIKE THEY HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO
DO.
GO TO A SOCCER GAME.
ENJOY YOUR LIFE.
IS THERE A LIST OF ALL OF THE
LIBERAL BOYCOTTS?
>> DANNY DEUTSCH SAID YOU OWN
EVERYTHING.
IF YOU SUPPORT A POLITICIAN YOU
OWN EVERYTHING.
>> I THINK IT'S BETTER TO TRY TO
BE DANNY TRAHOE AND NOT DANNY
DEUTSCH.
THIS IS LINKING INNOCENT PEOPLE
TO A HORRIFIC EVENT AND
INSTIGATE A MOB ON TWITTER.
THIS IS MOB ACTION.
IT'S NOT A BOYCOTT.
IT'S MORE LIKE GET THESE PEOPLE!
PITCHFORK.
HE SAID THAT.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT "THE FIVE"
WE CAN READ THE MOOD OF A
NATION.
EVEN IF WE WANTED TO STAY
CERTAIN THINGS, WE WAKE EVERY
MORNING AND ASK OURSELVES
WHETHER WE WILL BE A PLUS OR A
MINUS.
>> I AM A PLUS.
>> YOU ARE A PLUS!
YOUR VIEWERS ARE NO DIFFERENT.
THEY GO TO WORK THINKING I WILL
MAKE SOMEBODY PAY.
AT MSNBC YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF:
DO YOU WANT TO WAKE UP EVERY
MORNING AND MAKE A TERRIBLE WEEK
WORSE?
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
THEY ARE NOT READING THE MOOD OF
THE NATION.
THEY ARE NOT CHECKING THE
THERMOSTAT.
THEY SAY SWING VOTERS HAVE BLOOD
ON THEIR HANDS.
YOU ARE ESCALATING DEMONIZING
THESE PEOPLE.
CAN YOU DISAGREE WITH PEOPLE AND
CALM DOWN.
THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
WHEN PEOPLE CRIT SIZE THE
PRESIDENT, HIS SUPPORTERS?
>> PEOPLE FELT THE SAME WAY WHEN
PEOPLE WENT AFTER PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
THE OUTRAGE MACHINE IS ACTIVE ON
BOTH SIDES.
I RECALL A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
I GOT A MESSAGE I COULD NOT GO
TO HOME DEPOT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE THE OWNER OF HOME
DEPOT MADE A COMMENT THAT HE WAS
GOING TO GIVE TO THIS
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN.
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT FOR YEARS BEGGED FOR
HOME DEPOT COME INTO THE INNER
CITY OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
OH, GOD, I HAVE A COUPON.
I NEED TO GO TO HOME DEPOT
BECAUSE THE BOY COT BEGINS.
I RAN TO HOME DEPOT AND WANTED
TO PUT ON A DISGUISE BUT I
REALIZED NO ONE LOOKS LIKE ME.
SOME PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT WERE
CRITICIZING NETFLIX.
I CANNOT.
BOYCOTT STARBUCKS AND NIKE.
AT&T.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED THAT.
THIS IS FREE SPEECH.
IF YOU RUN FOR CONGRESS, I MIGHT
GIVE YOU A NICKEL OR TWO.
I WON'T GIVE YOU ALL MY MONEY.
I MIGHT EVEN THROW A FUNDRAISER.
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU AND LIKE YOU.
>> THAT'S NICE OF YOU.
>> HELL YEAH!
DO YOU THINK I AM SCARED?
HELL NO!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> LAWRENCE, DID YOU GO TO THE
GYM TODAY?
>> STILL LIGHT TODAY.
>> IS THE BOY COT WORKING?
>> I THINK IT IS WORKING AND I
DON'T CARE.
IT'S A CLEAN GYM AND THAT'S THE
ONLY THING I CARE ABOUT.
>> IT IS THE CLEANEST GYM.
THE POINT THAT BOTHERS ME ABOUT
THIS DEBATE IS THE HYPOCRISY.
SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT IS THE
ONLY ONE ESCALATING THINGS.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE PRESIDENT
ARE NOT FAR APART.
IT'S ONLY ONE SIDE TELLING THE
OTHER SIDE TO CALM DOWN.
EVERYTHING IS TAKEN SO
PERSONNEL.
THE DEMOCRATS CALL THE
REPUBLICANS HATEFUL PEOPLE.
ANY TIME WE LIKE SOMETHING, WE
ARE THE RACISTS.
THEY ARE THE ONES LIKE WE SAW ON
TV SAYING SHOW UP TO PEOPLE'S
HOMES WITH PITCH FORKS.
WHEN WE DON'T LIKE SOMETHING,
THIS IS A BOYCOTT BUT NOT COMING
WITH GUNS.
>> IT'S LIKE YOU SAY YOU DON'T